today dice provided fans with more
details about how Battlefield 2042's
return to a class-based system will work
including information on its new weapon
proficiency system at launch Battlefield
2042 featured Specialists unique
characters who each had a special
ability or Gadget but all weapons were
available to all characters meaning that
they didn't really have roles like in
past Battlefield games dice stated that
many players found them to be polarizing
for example it was hard to tell at a
glance what enemy player could do and
the dev quickly began putting together a
team to analyze what could be changed
based on fan feedback the result is not
that Specialists are going away entirely
but that they will instead be
categorized into four classes
Battlefield fans know and love assault
support engineer and Recon unlike some
previous Battlefield games where certain
classes could only use certain weapon
types Battlefield 2042 will instead
introduce weapon proficiencies for each
class these serve as an extra incentive
for a class to use a particular weapon
type but doesn't restrict them from
using other weapon types assault players
for example will receive extra ammo
magazines when using an assault rifle
while support players using an SMG will
enjoy a faster draw time the Recon class
will naturally want to lean into sniper
rifles thanks to a constant steady scope
and Engineers will benefit from improved
dispersion while using light machine
guns while crouched or prone in a match
class icons will now be displayed above
the heads of players which will help
identify what class a player is and what
gadgets they might be bringing into a
firefight certain gadgets will be
restricted to Specialists within a
particular class such as engineer
Specialists now being the only class
with access to rocket launchers this in
turn will make the game more balanced as
the team no longer has to plan around
every specialist having access to every
free Gadget as a result loadouts will
now be per class with every specialist
within that role having access to those
loadouts dice said that the current
loadouts will be wiped when update 3.2
arrives and players will need to rebuild
them from scratch the update is slated
to arrive later this month in other FPS
news hyenas is offering PC Alpha players
the chance to play its brand new
plundership map we took Manhattan this
weekend Alpha 1.11 begins on Friday
January 20th at 9 00 a.m Pacific time
and 12 p.m Eastern and ends Monday
January 23rd at 1 pm Pacific Time 4 pm
Eastern during this time players will be
able to test out the newest we took
Manhattan map which features New York
references from the Brooklyn Bridge to
Wall Street with the map centerpiece
being the Statue of Liberty located in
Liberty Hall developer creative assembly
has also revealed the following three
Alpha test dates for the coming months
weekend 2 is February 17 18th to 20th
weekend 3 is March 10th to the 13th and
weekend 4 is March 31st to April 3rd I
finally got a code to play so I know
what I'll be doing tomorrow and if you
want a shot at taking part you can still
sign up at playhenas.com let me know if
you're still a big Battlefield 2042
player and I'll see you tomorrow